[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره مرحبا بكم بعد وصوله للدوحه رئيس
مجلس السياده الانتقاليه عبد الفتاح
البرهان يعقد مباحثات مع امير قطر الشيخ
تميم بن حمد الثاني بشان التطورات في
السودان والدوحه تجدد موقفها الداعي الى
ضروره وقف القتال في السودان وعبر البرهان
عن شكره لدوله قطر على الموقف الداعم
للسودان في التطورات الميدانيه البرهان
يصدر مرسوما دستوريا يقضي بحل قوات الدعم
السريع استنادا الى ما سماها تداعيات
تمردهم على الدوله وانتهاكاتهم ضد
المواطنين ومستشار قائده قوات الدعم
السريع يرد بانهم لا يعترفون بقرار
البرهان وسيواصلون معاركهم ضد الجيش الى
تطورات الشان الفلسطيني قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي تشن حمله اعتقالات في مناطق
متفرقه بالضفه الغربيه الاعتقالات تركزت
في مخيم دهيشه بمدينه بيت لحم حيث اندلعت
مواجهه بين قوات الاحتلال وشب الفلسطينيين
اسفرت عن وقوع اصابات مجله فرانس فوتبول
الفرنسيه تكشف عن قائمه المرشحين للحصول
على الكره الذهبيه لعام 2023 القائمه تضم
من الاسماء العربيه اللاعب المغربي
سيمبونو والمصري محمد صلاح في حين تشهد
غياب اللاعب البرتغالي كريستيانو رونالدو
لاول مره منذ عشرين عاما
كمان الان